Wolverine vs Deadpool something that
fans may want to see even more than
Wolverine versus the Hulk and now I'm
not talking about the one scene that we
got in that one movie called x-men
origins Wolverine
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
yeah that actually happened but luckily
for us they kept Ryan Reynolds and the
actual Deadpool movies were amazing and
now it's official a new Deadpool movie
is in the works over at Marvel Studios
so Deadpool is finally entering the MCU
but a big question is could there be a
Wolverine vs. Deadpool movie and to make
it even better could it be with Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine well according to a
recent report it is possible
quick reminder only two days left in my
Infinity Gauntlet and G fuel giveaway so
be sure to click the link in the
description down below and subscribe
when notifications turned on to enter
now this report comes from Mikey Sutton
he's pretty well known in the community
at this point and he's been right about
some major things in the past
specifically when Spiderman first
entered the MCU in civil war and
recently that spider-man was still going
to remain in the MCU and this report
from Mikey about Wolverine and Deadpool
says that even though Hugh Jackman and
Ryan Reynolds have been joking about
this for years insiders have told Mikey
Sutton that there is a possibility that
Hugh Jackman could return as Wolverine
and of course Ryan Reynolds returning to
play Deadpool for a Wolverine and
Deadpool movie sources tell Mikey that
Disney wants to offer Hugh Jackman
truckloads of cash to return as Logan
one more time to face that pole in an
r-rated buddy picture right now it's
just in the discussion phase and there's
been no deal whatsoever with Hugh
Jackman yet so this is Mikey's report
about a Wolverine and Deadpool movie and
it is true Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman have been joking around about
this for a very long time and Ryan
Reynolds has been very open about the
fact that he's been trying to get Hugh
Jackman to return as Wolverine for a
very long time and he would love for him
to return there are even times and
interviews where Hugh Jackman said that
Wolverine is going to be back your buddy
Ryan Reynolds and he said there probably
won't be another standalone Deadpool
movie and then he thought that he said I
continued to do full-court press for
Hugh Jackman to to come back to no avail
is it nice yeah God God knows he's just
been failing constantly
that's what have we seen the last of
Wolverine Oh Wolverine he'll be back
someone's gonna ply him I don't know not
you though no Bo Ryan is he's relentless
he keeps coming back to me well there's
really no secret that I think everyone
would love to see Deadpool and Wolverine
together especially now in the MCU and
of course Ryan is still hoping for it
and according to this report Disney is
going to throw a lot of money at Hugh
Jackman that combined with the fact that
the rights to Wolverine are now owned by
Marvel Studios and Disney may be enough
to entice you Jackman to return for one
more film or at least a cameo although
my keys report does say that Marvel
Studios would like an r-rated buddy film
now there's been a lot of talk about
Deadpool remaining rated R even though
he's over at Marvel Studios and Disney
now and recently in an interview when
Ryan Reynolds confirmed that Marvel
Studios is working on another Deadpool
film at this very moment he did say that
his whole team from Fox came over to
Marvel Studios so we can pretty much
assume that it's going to remain rated R
Joker just had a crazy amount of success
now being the highest-grossing rated R
film ever
but Deadpool and Deadpool too are right
up there with it so the previous
Deadpool movies clearly work rated R so
Marvel's not going to mess with that
which means that if we did get a
Deadpool and Wolverine movie you can
expect a lot of gore and a lot of
profanity which if they are sticking
true to the characters and who they
really are that's expected and should
happen now many people may be asking how
exactly could this be possible since the
last time that we saw Wolverine or Logan
in the movie Logan he was dead well
there really are some pretty simple
solutions and one is to remember that
Fox no longer owns the rights to
Deadpool or Wolverine or any of the
x-men characters and as far as Marvel
Studios and most of the fans are
concerned the Fox universe and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are two
completely different things so one way
to bring him back is to simply ignore
everything that happened over at Fox
ignore the fact that he died in Logan
this wouldn't really be that big of a
deal you could just play off of a
different story and it would essentially
be a remake and if this movie did happen
it would probably be a one-off movie in
so contingency on storylines wouldn't
really matter and that's another big
reason for Marvel to do this as well do
a one-off movie just to bring Hugh
Jackman back as a Wolverine it would be
a great play by Marvel everybody would
go see this movie and it would probably
take the number one spot for rated our
movie but there are ways to fuse it into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe especially
with the upcoming phase four and phase
five phase four is going to be extremely
important to the MCU and phase five is
going to be just as important as well
because it's going to pick up after
everything in phase four has happened
and it's pretty well known at this point
in time that phase four is going to
introduce the multiverse Kevin Feige has
recently said in an interview after Cece
XP that the multiverse is the future of
the MCU which obviously means multiple
alternate realities so the idea would be
that Deadpool goes into a different
reality where Logan or Wolverine exists
and this would be Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine this would be a really easy
way to bypass the whole Logan is
technically dead thing and it would make
sense because it would make the audience
know that Hugh Jackman's Wolverine isn't
going to be an essential part of the MCU
because he doesn't exist in the main MC
of timeline and this would be a way that
everybody would win the fans would win
because we would finally see Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine go up against Ryan
Reynolds's Deadpool or see the two of
them work together and Marvel Studios
would win because they would make all of
the profit that the movie would bring in
and it would be a lot not to mention
they would make an awesome movie and it
doesn't affect their main MCU timeline
and future phases but that's not the
only way that this film could happen
there's something that the MCU and
Deadpool two have in common and that is
time travel hi this is a toughy
yes you're are you practicing a little
ooh that is so much harder than I
thought
oh that makes two of us so that's
another way that this movie could be
done
Deadpool could simply go back in time
and at the end of Deadpool to Yukio and
negasonic fixed Deadpool's time-travel
device allowing Deadpool to go back in
time Oh
just fix it 11 or I'll take it to the
Genius Bar Cape was gonna kill you when
you find out never heard of him
why do you think I'm helping him and one
of the people that he actually went back
in time and visited was Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine now of course it wasn't a new
scene it was just a clip from the x-men
origins Wolverine and the new Deadpool
thrown in it the timeline but something
very similar to this could be done and
Deadpool would make fun of it and that's
really the great thing about the
Deadpool movies is that he breaks the
fourth wall so if this movie did end up
being made Deadpool could and probably
would
Deadpool would say something around the
lines of don't worry this won't affect
your precious MCU timeline or maybe even
say something along the lines of don't
worry Doctor Strange we'll fix it
because we know that Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness is probably
going to be about Doctor Strange fixing
alternate timelines that were created
during Avengers endgame because we know
that several alternate realities were
created during the movie Loki escaped
with the tesseract in 2012 they knows
from 2014 left his timeline to the main
timeline and died Gamora from 2014 now
exists in the main MCU timeline which
means that severely affects the
guardians of the galaxy coming together
in the 2014 timeline and not to mention
who knows what Captain America really
did when he returned to the 1940s so
with all of these alternate realities
created that Doctor Strange will
presumably have to fix it wouldn't be
that hard to make another one where
Deadpool and Wolverine have their own
movie and if we do end up getting a
movie it's going to be absolutely
incredible because the two of them are
essentially the same person now of
course obviously they have two
differences but if you take a look at
their powers they're not too different
they both have the ability to heal and
basically can't die they could both
regenerate they can both have
get cut off and still not die and not to
mention they're both super intense
now of course Wolverine has a dementia
him all throughout his body and he uses
his famous claws to attack and Deadpool
is known for using his katanas and guns
all of which probably won't affect the
other person that much Deadpool
literally had all of his limbs blown off
in Deadpool too and he still survived so
we are in for a very very big movie
not to mention probably a very brutal
movie if this does happen and of course
it will probably be hilarious as well
now again just to remind you Mikey
Sutton's report does not say that this
is definitely going to happen he simply
said that Marvel Studios is talking
about it wants it to happen plans to
throw a lot of money at Hugh Jackman but
Hugh Jackman has not said anything yet
so this isn't confirmed but it's
definitely something that I think
everybody would like but let me know
your thoughts about this I'm pretty sure
I know the answer but would you like a
Wolverine and Deadpool movie and if so
how would you like to see it happen let
me know in the comments down below also
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe but with notifications turned
on and click the link in description
down below to enter my Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway again only two days left I'm
also giving away an Xbox one or ps4 at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers the winner gets to choose
all you have to do to enter that is to
be subscribed and notification turned on
like the video and leave a comment down
below as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof